over the past month a caravan of Central
American migrants has gradually made its
way up from Honduras through Mexico all
the way to Tijuana opposite San Diego at
one point Mexican authorities claimed
they broke up - the group an American
media of course dutifully reported that
they did but they didn't that was just a
PR gesture and a temporary one in fact
during parts of the trip
Mexican police escorted the migrants
northward in other words the Mexican
government abetted illegal immigration
into this country as it has done for
many years well tonight the caravan is
on our southern border rather than wait
for the crossing station in San Ysidro
to open many of them just jumped the
fence some waved Honduran flags when
they got to the top and that tells you
everything when you arrive in a country
to contribute to it and to assimilate
into its culture you don't wave the flag
of a foreign nation that's when you do
in triumph when you invade a country
according to border control at least one
member of the caravan has already
admitted to being a member of ms-13 all
of us should worry us there are only a
few hundred people in this caravan but
there are billions more around the world
who live amid violence and poverty and
virtually every single one of them would
like to relocate to San Diego the left
argues we have no moral right to stop
any of them from doing that here's
attorney Nichole Ramos of Tijuana
denouncing the US government as criminal
for trying to enforce our own federal
law Watch rejecting asylum seekers at
the port of entry you know what you're
doing you know you turn people away you
come
way that they are breaking the law by
entering you legally you are breaking
the law and you are forcing dad to break
the law that's why we have Caravan yeah
it's definitely someone you want in
control over public policy screaming
into a bullhorn this is not immigration
immigration happens with the consent of
the host country this is happening by
force without our consent a government
that cared about its own citizens
wouldn't allow it to happen bad things
happen when you leave the door open
every homeowner knows that the left is
demanding that we leave our door open
any attempt at self defense is immoral
they tell us from the safety of their
segregated neighborhoods where they all
live illegal immigrants are amazing
people they say far better than you are
mister entitled American last week we
had a conversation with Enrique Acevedo
of Univision and he made that point if
you're right up against a country that's
totally out of control as people are
shooting each other in the numbers you
just described why wouldn't you be
terrified to let them in well I think
you're not getting the criminals you're
getting the best of Mexico the people
who are willing to work two or three
shifts a day the people who are
law-abiding citizens did enough to try
to provide a better future for their
family the people who are fleeing that
violence that's what you're getting nut
rapists and criminals we don't know that
of course because we have more we didn't
know actually we don't